but if I my headphones in and you see me
in the middle of a workout please don't
ask for a picture or video yeah that's
like fairies don't ya absolutely I mean
that's a total distraction and what
people don't realize how much your
offseasons oh yeah
but even then I mean I'm still working
and could you imagine always having
someone do that creepy [ __ ] with it with
the camera but the camera phone they
forget that you're holding heavy weight
yeah
and that's and that's the biggest
problem is that here you are trying to
focus and imagine doing like a 500 pound
squad or something like that and someone
you hear
snap snap or this that or someone doing
the corner face selfie on you and you
can get injured so or if your techniques
i'll who knows if ents up then you got
the lifting wars alright mister to
limpio how about the rounded back yeah
you don't talk to him like dude head
movement i'll looks like some 16 year
olds in his basement like god dammit man
so that's that's the more difficult part
and we're finding more with and i hate
to say it but with the millennials yeah
more they ever is that they'll be in
there flex in with their shirt half up
and this net and you're like amen you're
in front of the dumbbell rack doing this
you got to show some better gym
etiquette and stuff like that so yeah
fortunately enough at arm wresting
you've seen it we have more middle-aged
guys that have been around weights long
enough to kind of like slap these young
kids up and say hey look that's not how
we get it done let's be respectful
because it's a pretty hardcore gym but
yet is clean right and that's what we
try to keep their butt and other gems
abroad like when we my girl and i we go
train it can become a frickin problem so
kind of have to call the gym ahead of
time to let them know you're coming in
and then just say nicely hey I'm in here
if you want your staff because staff
will do it too oh yeah you know my staff
will do it too so you got to let them
know ahead of time I'm coming in we're
going to Train afterwards hey we can get
a group shot or whatever for like 5-10
minutes that's it that's how long when
you say train I got how long is the
training session for you 90 minutes on
average
any minute yeah we're hitting it we're
hitting individual muscle good friend oh
sure when you but when you go abroad
like bodybuilding is so much like don't
get me wrong it's pretty big here but
abroad if you're like Tom Cruise out in
that bigger money and be like all ours
like you just mentioned earlier like how
you're going to Australia yeah I
remember spending out entire month there
doing a whole tour all the way from the
bottom all the way up to Darwin nearly
damn equator and back how big is
Australia it's I mean you know it's big
enough you know and and as far as the
bodybuilding scene it does Trump the US
and some in some areas just for body the
wines that you think I don't know but I
do know this that at one point in time
sourcing ager was down there quite a bit
you know he did a lot of seminar down
there
a lot of those photos that you see of
him back in the pumping iron days yeah
the black and white have said you know
that's over in Coogee Beach is it really
an over at the Opera House but he never
had like Australia they've never had
like a big time not being like no Ben no
how about this one I was running on the
stairs and this you know you passed by
the sticking people all the time
I'm pass wise guy and it did you know
just get dudes Jack and I seen there all
the time and it always looks like you
has something on his nose like I'm like
I'm like like a bugger or I don't know
what's going on
tomorrow and then we get to it may be a
mole but I got to pay remember that
immediately nice big handsome do like
big dude cut in but not young like I
mean he might be like a kid genetics
like I might be 50 he's up there Rob or
some gray hair yeah I would say he's
between 45 and 55 but phenomenal shape
tan is [ __ ] in all Lululemon which
usually red flag that's interesting
that's an interesting thing so we get to
the top and I'm stretching getting done
and he goes eh brother see here all the
tile it's up man and I finally get close
enough to look it's a nose ring
well sir you can't now let that you
can't be 55 even 40s with a nose ring
right that's your lenny kravitz
unless you're living another then even
though later want to pull it off he can
pull it off but Johnny Depp is still
dressing like he's not with the nose
ring though a wizard no Johnny Depp just
like you Jasper Oh 24/7 yeah and Jesus
52 3 or whatever he is that now it's
getting a little bit edge on Johnny
Tremain necklace is a little bit no this
did bit this dude had a earring change
like every time you want to deal out I
was going that's
yeah I immediately judged yeah I've seen
guys within they're one of the better in
a spray tan and then the all Lululemon
that is a red flag you cannot even
roughhouse Sunday club if you have
atomic clubs no DJ have noses you're not
interrupt a sunday Club which last time
you saw mail is another thing besides
any credits go III and I stand there all
the time if you listeners using me like
[ __ ] my boy my turn one lemon running
you wait in Seattle
Rob who owns amped CrossFit which I
recommend you go and see how to awesome
gym he is a CrossFit instructor young
very good looking at nose like he's
black and Jewish he's got some mix or
met either way that he's this really
good-looking guy he's got a nose ring
but but the way he moves off if you're
in your 20s you're like in your across
better he gets away with nope I actually
personally I asked for laddle I like I
like nose rings in on black guys some
guys can pull it off on black on black
guys you mean uh if you've got that sort
of like no hair on your body and you're
kind of styling like the Lenny Kravitz
look then I can I can I can you just I
just gotta bail them forever and then
you just [ __ ] know with a guy my age
with the spray tan that's no problem
hey no this here's a [ __ ] nuts for an
email list in this [ __ ] shelf if you
have a nose ring you're not too
popularly Krauts take that [ __ ] out I'm
going to show you the before and after
video on my Instagram and Facebook
I think it's on my facebook right now my
fanpage and it is crazy man I don't know
how he does it
Brian Brian thought I was [ __ ]
Brian's like no those are two different
dogs would be two different dogs look at
them they look exactly know that no one
can do that I'm like dude I get it I
don't believe it I didn't believe it
either but i'ma tell you this is like
his thing this is what he does
and I asked him like how do you do it
he's like brother that's like someone
asked you how do you do stand-up how do
you do podcasts and how do you do MMA
how do you do jiu-jitsu like it's what I
do like remember when I train these dogs
for a secret service this five day
intensive training for these dogs on the
mission because it's obviously it's so
much more extreme laughter sniff out
bombs and all that [ __ ] and attack
Middle Eastern guys but he was saying
how yeah it's rough so he was saying how
they put him through the same training
but it
five months every day seven days a week
think about those dogs and I was like
damn give me one of those he's like you
don't want one of those
he's like people who try to place those
dogs in homes it's trouble those dogs
they're not and if your son you know my
15 month old son if that dog's evening
comes by his bowl Ian ripped even
readies hey about forget the football
career that's gone so yeah what about
stuff like that I'm telling you I know
the help when says mal wants their
trouble man Joe getting bit I I've heard
all that I've had a million dogs in my
life I trust this guy in this breeder
opposed to later today but Johnny man
this guy is a straight-up miracle worker
it's insane wait TC this [ __ ] it's mind
blown I I can't wait see I always
thought that Cesar Milan guy I thought
before I watch the show like is so
gimmick Iike I thought it wasn't really
true but damn it when you actually watch
the show yeah well you're seeing Susan
Melania bit no by lab using that [ __ ]
hilarious a chocolate lab flexers hand
out of all dogs he's all and he's like
just stay there I got to stick us god
dammit alright I'm bleeding
yes labs like get the [ __ ] out in room
you never see them get that hilarious I
laugh use me YouTube that on your own
time but it is hilarious yeah chocolate
labs is not up in here Caesar real
problem lab who has a problem lab